in the 20th century in the early 21st
century what do you think works well and
what is broken about government the
fundamental thing is that we can't
easily and peacefully start new opt-in
governments
and startup governments yeah and what do
I mean by that is basically
um
you can start a new company you can
start a new community you can start a
new currency even these days you don't
have to beat the former CEO in a duel to
start a new company
um you don't have to become head of the
World Bank to start a new currency okay
because of this
yes if you can if if you're if you want
to you can join I don't know
uh Microsoft or name some companies at
GameStop and you can try to reform it
okay or you can start your own
and the fact that both options exist
mean that you know you've you can
actually just start from scratch and
that's just I mean the same reason we
have a clean piece of paper right I've
mentioned this actually in in the
network State book I'll just quote this
bit but we want to be able to start a
new state peacefully for the same reason
we want to Bear plot of Earth a blank
sheet of paper an empty text buffer a
fresh start or a clean slate because you
want to build something new without
historical constraint right for the same
reason you hit plus and do docs.new you
know like create a new Doc it's for the
same reason right because you don't
backspace you don't have just like 128
bytes of space 120 kilobytes and just
have to backspace the old document for
creating the new one so that's a
fundamental thing that's wrong with
today's garments and it's a meta point
right because it's not any one specific
reform it's a meta reform of being able
to start new countries
okay so that's one problem but there you
know you could push back and say that's
that's a feature because you know a lot
of people argue that tradition is power
through generation if you try a thing
long enough which is the way I see
marriage there's value to this struggle
and the journey you take through the
struggle and you grow and you develop
ideas together you grow until actually
philosophically together and that's the
idea of a Nations that spans Generations
that you have a tradition that becomes
more
that that strives towards the truth and
is able to arrive there or no not arrive
but take steps towards there through the
generations so you may not want to keep
starting new governments you may want to
uh stick to the old one and improve it
one step at a time so just because
you're having a fight inside a marriage
doesn't mean you should get a divorce
and go on Tinder and start dating around
that's the uh that's the pushback so
it's not obvious that there's a strong
future to have sure to launch new
governments there's several different
kind of lines of attack or or debate or
whatever on this right first is uh yes
there's obviously value to tradition and
uh you know people say this is Lindy and
that's Lindy it's being proven for a
long time and so on but of course
there's a tension between tradition and
Innovation you know like going to the
Moon wasn't Lindy
just it was awesome and you know like
artificial intelligence is something
that's very new new is good right and
this is a tension within Humanity
actually itself because you know it's
way older than all of these nations I
mean humans are tens of thousands of
years old answers to humans are millions
of years old right and you go back far
enough and the time that we know today
of the sessile farmer and Soldier
is if you go back far enough you want to
be truly traditional well we're actually
descend from hunter-gatherers who are
mobile and wandered the world and there
weren't borders and so on they kind of
went where they want right and you know
people have you know had done historical
reconstructions of like skeletons and
and stuff like that and
uh many folks who report that the
transition to Agriculture and being
sessile
um resulted in you know diminution of
height you know people had like tooth
decay and stuff like that the skeletons
people had traded off upside for
stability right that's what the state
was that was what these sessile kinds of
things right now of course
um they they had more likelihood of
living uh consistently you could support
larger population sizes but it had lower
quality of life right and so the
hunter-gatherer error you know maybe
that's actually our Collective
recollection of a Garden of Eden where
people you know just like a a spider
kind of knows innately how to build webs
or a beaver knows how to build dams you
know some people theorize that uh the
entire Garden of Eden is like
um a sort of built-in neural network
recollection of this you know
pre-sessile era we're able to roam
around just pick off fruits and so on
low population density so point is that
I think what we're seeing is a V3 you go
from the hunter-gatherer to the farmer
and Soldier the sessile nations are here
and they've got borders and so on to
kind of the V3 which is the digital
Nomad the new hunter-gatherer we're
going back to the future because you
know it's even older than Nations is no
Nations right even more traditional than
tradition is
you know being International right and
so we're actually tapping into that
other huge thread in humanity which is
the desire to explore Pioneer wander
innovate you know kind of thing that's
important to make America great again is
to dissolve it completely into Oblivion
no that's a joke I know it's a joke well
humor I'm learning this new thing yes a
new thing for the role the chatbot
emulation isn't fully working there yeah
yeah glitch that's we're in the in the
beta and let me say one other thing
about this which is
you know there are I mean everybody in
the world to for okay let's say I don't
know what percentage let's say
99.99 uh or it's rounds to that number
of
political discourse in the US focuses on
trying to fix the system if those folks
I mean 0.01 of the energy is going
towards building a new system that seems
like a pretty good portfolio strategy
right or 100 are supposed to go and edit
this code base from 200 something years
ago I mean the most American thing in
the world is going and you know leaving
your country in in search of a better
life America was founded 200 years ago
by the founding fathers it's not just a
nation of immigrants it's a nation of
immigrants right immigration you know
from other countries to the US and
actually also immigration within the US
there's this amazing YouTube video
called
um it's like 50 states U.S population I
think 1792 it says 2050s they've got a
simulation so you just stop it at 2019
or 2020. but it shows that like Virginia
was like number one early on and then it
lost ground in like New York gained and
then like Ohio was a big deal in the
early 1800s and it was like father of
presidents in general all these
presidents and later Illinois and
Indiana and then California really came
up in the 20th century right during the
Great Depression and now we're entering
the modern era where like Florida and
Texas have risen in New York and
California have dropped and so
Interstate competition it's actually
just like inter-currency competition
you've got trading pairs right you you
know sell BTC by eth you sell you know a
Solana or Zeke you know sell Monero by Z
cash right each of those trading pairs
gives you signal for today on this
currency is down or up relative to this
other currency in the same way each of
those migration pairs someone goes from
New York to Ohio Ohio to California
gives you information on the
desirability of different states you can
literally form a pairs Matrix like this
over time very much like link Matrix
that's shaped American a huge way and so
you know you ask a if this nation of
immigrants that was founded by men
younger than us by the way the founding
fathers were often in their 20s right
who
um you know endorse the concept of a
proposition Nation who've given rise to
a country of Founders and and Pioneers
uh who've literally gone to the Moon
right
um those folks would think that this is
the end of History
that that's it we're done like we we've
done everything else I mean there's
people in technology who believe and I
agree with them that we can go to Mars
they might be able to end death but we
can't innovate on something that was 230
years old
you know
so there is a balance certainly to
strike uh the the American experiment is
fascinating nevertheless so one argument
you can make is actually that we're in
the very early days of this V2 if so
what you describe as V2 you could make
the case that we're not ready for V3
that we're just actually uh trying to
figure out the V2 thing you're trying to
like
get when are we ever ready
now again we'll go back to marriage I
think and having kids kind of thing I
think everyone has kids is never really
ready to be kids this whole point you
dive in